hey everybody this is Jenny slate one of
my favorite people comedians actress
actress comedian thank you thanks for
being here
pleasure I like the fort you've made
yeah I love it I didn't expect I was
gonna get to have something like this I
also picked two short of a short
children women shorts when a short is
too short
yeah build yourself before yeah yeah no
no I'm good morning it yeah hi
that's nothing one two three shelf the
Jenny slate show no yeah your show you
do whatever you want or whatever sorry
oh you do yeah I saw Alison Lynne said
it what did she say she said and she
said [ __ ]
Gilligan's Hetal till I watch some of
your other in the head and [ __ ] she is
lovely and she said [ __ ] so I can say it
you have a bow I asked for it
tell the people your choice of camera
what you said when they gave you the
boat give me the bow because I'm a
present for the present aka a gift for
now that means you married yeah do you
ever just hold it up when a fella comes
up and they're like you want to slow Gin
Fizz if someone did that to me I would
murder my husband and go without me and
that's
cool an we have ever started when you're
scared and you're holding your butts so
tight that like your fart like it's like
it normally would be like you know but
like you're so scared that you're like
that was like it's like it comes out
you're a scream yeah yo I can't make
that noise you believe in ghosts
I did you told me about it ghosts yeah
in your home okay so my parents moved in
and my mom finds a packet of letters
that are written to the woman who was
the mistress of the house and they're
love letters but they're not from her
husband they're from a captain so-and-so
of the SS yeah and then that night my
mom is like raw and come to bed she
smelled his pipe and then she rolled
over and he's like yeah he was like a
sleep she was like huh the nodes are
rubber in the house and he's smoking
apart and so my dad's like so he got
like like an old tennis racket cage
again today I died so um he goes out
into the hallway and he looks over the
railing and sees coming up the stairs
and old a sea captain like a sea captain
just walking up the stairs with the pipe
yeah
that's terrifying that's what he saw and
he was like it was there and it wasn't
there it was there and it wasn't there
it was like flickering it's just like
that he was like nut what oh wait oh
yeah oh no hypothetical you and your
husband Dean Dean are attending a dinner
party and you're asked to bring
something but don't bring wine like what
you would bring dessert what's the
dessert you make um I make a lot of
cakes as you know I make a lot of cakes
and I make a lot of cookies is that a
fun way of saying cookies you know there
is a chef on Top Chef like 90 years ago
who in all seriousness was like well I
try to make the cookies and all of a
sudden the cookies are dead flat and I
like oh my god why did I think cookies
are the easiest thing to make and now
the cookies aren't even good what that
guy's just like you know who I like on
Sesame Street is that Cookie Monster
yeah Cookie Monster no Elmo the kooky
Watty yeah
what are some things that are not sexual
but you find sexual um like penises
um nakedness um like when two naked
people lie on top of each other having
my tits out wearing sexy underwear non
stop wearing underpants I'm weird weird
having my tits out look at the dog you
let out my tits are out
I'm so afraid of those situations that
happen to girls when they go under the
water jumping or in a wave and they come
up and wave pool Oh going down a
waterslide out the words out Oh tits out
I once saw some balls hanging below a
bathing suit on a very elderly gentleman
it was like very odd it wasn't like it
was like peeking out it was like
dingdong I'm a grandfather clock and
this is the part of the clock that
everyone sees it was like the longest
the longest thing I've ever seen in my
life
so Jenny I thought it would be fun I
make my own shampoo boy would you want
to make shampoo with me yes I'm gonna
show you how to make my shampoo yeah
there's a lot of advantages to making
your own shampoo one it's fun here's an
oil you can use peppermint oh there's
something that you don't know if you put
a lot of peppermint oil it's
invigorating you can also use it as a
body wash and it'll feel good on your
butthole yeah get that pepper but good
go get that pepper but that's why I
called my Peppo whole thing wink wink
wink
golly candy cane line back there
don't you have any sort of like and
sorbitol or gelatin or something to make
this into more of like a goop like this
so Finn you pour this thin [ __ ] all over
your head oops
this is too thin it's like a Beverly
Hills soup kitchen yeah about my hair
products J's lay it smells like candy
but it is and so don't you dare eat it
says the one don't see outside person
Jenny slate you're one of the funniest
people I know thank you so much for
being here
I love gabbing with you thank you for
having me I love to gab with you as well
I'm so small in your